wo steckte die Maker Föhn and handy und
Nummer Auto das Michael die
mineralgruppe ist mega nützlich nur
leider werden beim Abbau von Michael
immer wieder Kindern
[Musik]
und willkommen
informiert
[Gelächter]
das fühlt sich gerade
[Musik]
wer das mager ist
und jetzt gehört
[Musik]
aber auf jeden Fall
da
drin
aber wie findet man
im Vorfeld
[Musik]
[Applaus]
indische Verhältnis sehr arm
ies staubelt
verdienen
ich möchte wissen
einfach
Organisation
über 22.000
Temperatur
für Elektroautos obwohl nachfragt immer
größer wird die lüter werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Stück
vor deiner illegalenverlängerung
das erste Mal machen weg
nach der Arbeit
[Musik]
der Vater verzählt mehr er sammli
trotzdem Unfall bitter es gibt keine
andere Jobs
eigentlich verboten ist
und sie sammle das was mir
so viele Produkt braucht
[Musik]
da drin sind die Mine irgendwo versteckt
na dann haben wir glücklich
[Musik]
im Auto
es ist ein komplizierter weg
aber dann können wir mit dem Auto
und dann mit der Autor
[Applaus]
und
überall
alles
er zeigt dass sie der Bagger hätte
das damals
immer wieder Behörde Mitarbeiter
sind dann müsstet mir egal
[Musik]
Arbeit
Manager da redet mit uns
oder das
nächste
Fahrrad
[Musik]
ob dann kriegt stimmig
jetzt
schon aber es war meine Hilfe
aber was passiert dann
wir lassen es am Schluss ihr seid mega
schön Handy oder Auto
beantworte mache ich mich zwischen
Handel und findet der 3,5
sammelt worden ist oder nicht
exportieren
[Musik]
der Abbau von Maika oftmals der
Kinderarbeit Erfolg hat sich Laster zu
entschlossen ab 1 januar 2018 natürlich
das Michael aus allen Produkten zu
entfernen das klar Statement von Beauty
Konzern Lush der Elektronikkonzern
Samsung schreibt mir dass sie versuchen
mehr Ersatzstoffe
oder Kunstharz
stellen können wir nicht zuverlässig
überprüfen
mehrere Firmen sind aber Mitglieder für
sogenannte lieferkettenorganisationen
zum Beispiel ABB Samsung BMW H&M
Mercedes-Benz Loreal Porsche und Migros
analysiert werden zusätzlich wird mit
Hilfsprojekten
[Musik]
umgesetzt wird doch mehrere Vorsprachen
E-Mails sprechen mir die
Verantwortlichen
Koordinatorin von der Partner
Hilfsorganisation
sprojekt
so bietet sie besonders Arme
familienalternative zu mir Geld
verdienen wann sie versprechen
hat hat es Stipendium bekommen mit dem
hat sie es Velo gekauft zum mit
heißkocher
[Musik]
Mitarbeitende die junge regelmäßig darum
Kinder haben schlecht ist und sie
organisieren Aktivitäten wie zum
Beispiel fußballtrainiert nach drei
Jahren endet die aktive Hilfsarbeit
Sozialleistungen
und sie zeigt mir ein staatliche
Kindergarten Initiative Spielsachen
das ist Familie besser geht und sie
darum ihre Kinder geschickt
[Applaus]
never
[Musik]
kann das Sie dass ich zufälligerweise
bin der
minexigative beliefert auf deren
projektdörfer
sind dürfen
Initiativen
dass sie Firmen
das will ich jetzt vor der
Verantwortlichen und rede mit der Chefin
von der Initiative der funny
hi how are you
Cannabis Zertifikation
[Musik]
the wellness tracing bringing the
children back to school finding
alternativ source für die heraus anders
sagen
um wirklich sicherstellen dass kein
kindergartenprodukten
verantwortlich oder müsste Firmen machen
schreibst mir die Kommentare und wenn du
noch mehr spannende Kanal